Hello I'm Jonathan Worth and as well as
being a freelance photographer,
I'm also a Senior Researcher at Newcastle
University's Open Lab in the UK.
The interviews you're about to hear are part
of a series that along with the web-platform
and connected classes, seeks to
create a space for a more
critical engagement with visual storytelling.
The following audio montage is of several
separate interviews including a
photographer, their subject
and someone who represents the audience.
The photographer is Dalia Khamissi and the subjects are
Aida Geadah, her daughter Lena and Jeanette Youssef.
The audience perspective is provided by documentary
filmmaker Benjamin Chesterton.
Dalia is a Lebanese photographer who began work as the Beirut Photo Editor
for the Associated Press back in 2005
Aida, Lena and Jeanette are all subjects from Dalia's project  "The Missing".
Benjamin is production director and co-founder of the film production company DuckRabbit.
His background was as a documentary producer for the BBC World Service
and his experiences of these, now blended audiences,
as well as his history with Dahlia's project, provide valuable insights.
Professor Saree Makdisi of the
University of California, Los Angeles
also provides some historical and
socio-political context.
In this edit of the interviews we're challenging ourselves to think in particular about
the theme "Evidence" and the question of believability.
Why should your audience believe you?
At the end of the session you'll be able to access the
extended versions of individual interviews, along with a deep-dive
interview with a 2014 World Press Photo
competition winner, Rena Effendi.
In the meantime we invite you to interrogate, reflect on and discuss the content we've edited.
To become what the journalist Dan Gilmore refers to as 'active users of media', rather than passive readers.
We're used to photographs being evidential.
The first hundred years of photography's
history established its reputation as
trace representation, a quotation from appearances.
It was something that required a human to make, but once the shutter was released
the process became a chemical one.
Even still, the photograph represents a point of view,
both literally and figuratively.
We have to choose how to edit the world.
We discern between important visual information and extraneous visual noise,
and we have to do this within messy,
chaotic and often very personal situations.
In Dalia Khamissy's project "The Missing" we hear how she tells the stories of people
through their homes, through their possessions and through their relatives.
We hear from those relatives what the process of sharing their stories is like,
and we hear the
filmmaker Benjamin Chesterton describe
the responsibilities of the professional
storyteller.
Although many of us are photographers,
we are the audience now and
as such it pays us to reflect on
what moves us and to reflect on why?
How can photographs of absence retain any evidential currency?
What case is being built? What is the overall narrative?
Is the historical account an impartial one?
What is Dalia's motivation and how have her outlets for that motivation evolved?
What is the motivation of the subjects?
Why do they agree to submit to such a
painful procedure?
What or who is the common ground for these various stakeholders?
And critically for us as image makers and visual storytellers, in a world where everyone in this piece can
theoretically publish their own story -
what are Dalia's various roles,
and those of the 21st century photographer?
Other questions will appear in the transcripts
and you'll have your own so please add
them, add your answers, add your comments
and add your notes into the platform as
you listen.
[Dalia] Merhaba my name is Dalia Khamissi and I'm a photographer based in Beirut Lebanon.
Since 2010 I have been working on the estimated 17,000 missing and forcibly disappeared
from the 1975 to 1990 Lebanese civil war.
I was 2 years old and this civil war started
and around 17 when it ended.
The town where I was born and raised suffered mostly during the last few years of the war.
I remember that sometimes suddenly the bombing would start again
and that we would run back to the house for shelter.
I actually remember days where
I witnessed bombs falling less than 30
meters away from the building
I remember my sister and I screamed in panic as we
were stuck in the corridor
not knowing where to hide as the sound of the bombs was getting nearer.
[Saree] The Lebanese civil war began in 1975
and ended in 1990.
[Jonathan] Saree Makdisi
[Saree] It was a war over the distribution of power among and between
different sectarian groups in the
country or really, more specifically,
the distribution of power among the elites
of different sectarian groups.
Fighting and displacements of population during
the war did often blend into tensions between
different sectarian communities
and at times degenerated into blind
inter-communal violence.
Exact numbers as to how many people were killed are not exactly clear
because really there was
no state to keep accurate records of
these kinds of things given the nature
of the war.
But, between 150 and 180 thousand people were killed.
This is in a population of around 3 million,
so it's pretty dramatic.
[Dalia] After I finished my photography years at university I knew
that I wanted to tell the stories of
people especially those who have
suffered Wars but, I was not prepared yet
to work on the wars I had lived.
In the summer of 2006 I witnessed the terrible
is really aggression on lebanon is
[News announcer]  "Israel's warning some 300,000 Lebanese to abandon their homes as it edges towards
a full-on ground invasion of  Southern Lebanon"
[Dalia] I was working for The Associated Press in Beirut as a Photo Editor.
I did not photograph back then, but I saw the war
through the eyes of the other photographers in the field.
The Summer war was the most terrible I had lived.
I was older now not a child anymore and
while my parents hid the graphic images
from us children, during the Civil War,
as a photo editor I had to stare at
photographs on the computer screen every day.
Images of the injured, the dead, the destruction, people crying over the death of their loved ones.
Heartbreaking photographs of people I related to.
So during the war of 2006, many international photographers
and journalists came to Lebanon to cover the
events.
[mixed news announcers] ... Hezbolla fired a  wave of highly advanced rockets...
meanwhile the bombardment of Lebanon continues at least 30 Lebanese..."
[Dalia] The country was full of foreign press.
The war lasted for 34 days
and the press was doing superb work, like a super work.
In November 2006 I quit the AP four months after the beginning of the war and I was damaged
like totally damaged.
I said at home most of the time after I quit.
Tears were falling from my eyes without me even
wanting to cry, as if my tears container
got very full and was now spilling over.
I went to the south of Lebanon the area
that suffered the most during the 2006
war and it was heavily bombarded.
Many villages and towns were flattened by the
bombing and I had seen those images
during the 2006 war but I had not seen them
through my eyes.
That day I had my camera with me and I entered homes that were destroyed and abandoned.
The furniture was still there and what really shocked me
was how much the private homes of people had become public.
I mean anyone anyone could enter them because there were no more doors anymore
and obviously no more inhabitants.
On the floors lay clothes of those who lived
there, sometimes photographs,  belongings, keys.
Even though there were no people to
photograph I said that those houses
told the stories of their owners.
Those spaces reminded me of how much my life turned into public during the war.
The war had forcibly turned my life from private to a public one,
the same as for those spaces.
So I took photographs of few houses and
then I returned to take more and more
and I then formed a series of photographs that I titled "Abandon Spaces".
I felt it was my way of reconciling with photograph.
After that project I started working on the
Lebanese issues especially those related
to women's rights until I decided to start
researching the subject of the missing.
The issue of the missing is considered
one of the most difficult ones in Lebanon.
[Saree] There were thousands of
kidnappings that took place during the war.
The kidnappings were sometimes for
ransom, sometimes for murder,
sometimes for execution and torture.
Sometimes for reprisal, sometimes for vengeance,
sometimes her personal vendettas. So it's
not clear necessarily why somebody's kidnapped.
But people would often disappear and then sometimes they'd be
released, sometimes somebody would pay
somebody and they'd get somebody released.
Very often people would be kidnapped, disappear and that would be that.
Nobody would know what what happens
to them.
Everybody knows somebody who was kidnapped
I personally know a neighbour of ours who was kidnapped and then held
for a few days and then released.
I have a relative who was kidnapped and released, I think the same day.
And one of my closest childhood friends was kidnapped with his parents and never heard from again.
And of course there's a big difference
between the casualties of killed and wounded
and those who are disappeared,
because killed or wounded I mean awful
is that is of course for the people
themselves and for their families and friends
and so forth, at least you know what happened.
Whereas people who just disappear you don't know what happens to them so there's no closure,
there's no resolution for the trauma.
Those responsible for the kidnappings for the
most part remain very close to power in Lebanon given the country's amnesty law right after the war.
They've been absolved of guilt and responsibility.
Certainly nobody's been held accountable for the crimes they committed during the war.
So basically the fates of those that disappeared in the war has never been resolved.
[Dalia] So through my photographs I try to tell
the stories of people who are left behind.
Those whose stories do not specifically interest the mainstream media.
The issue of the missing and kidnapped haven't been covered much lately.
So in my project I wanted to dig deeper
in the story -
to learn more about the different narratives behind the missing and the kidnapped.
At the beginning I photographed portraits, for example, of the families.
Then I learned about the belongings they kept of the victims.
With each family a different story, the same pain of course, but a different story and details.
In 2009 I met  Aida and Lena Gedeah.
Three years later in 2012 I called Lina the daughter of Aida to ask her
if she and her mother would allow me to take their photographs and tell their stories.
[Lina] Usually with journalists, I am cautious. I do not speak a lot.
But with Dalia, because I felt she was like us, like our friends, we started communicating with her and
I did not feel there will be a problem ... that she might convey the wrong message
because there are people who follow the scoop… but with Dalia I did not feel that.
But then when many years passed, we felt that the media was not doing anything anymore.
As if we are filling the pages of the newspapers. Nobody was listening to us. Nobody was doing anything.
[Jeanette] Not all media is the same. You have media that hurt with their stories
and you other media that helps you,
and you have other media that maybe waits for the scoop to take it..
[Lina] But after few years, there is no more scoop.
The scoop is at the first phase, then afterwards,
there should be more work, that the media works more.
[Dalia] After a month or two  I got in touch with Benjamin Chesterton from DuckRabbit.
We emailed back and forth and he was interested in my way of photograph.
I told him about the project of the missing and two months later
he decided to come to Beirut and work with me on that project for the BBC.
For three days Benjamin and I met mothers of victims of enforced disappearances.
We met with NGO people, MPs, ex-militia members,
Women telling about the last time they saw their children, their husbands.
They talked about their continuous struggle and their only wish to know the fate of their loved ones.
[Benjamin] Most of the interviews with the families were conducted in their mother tongue.
And obviously Dalia would conduct those...
..conduct those interviews, and I would
assist with really helping her to shape them.
so what is the story that we're
telling here?
And it's obvious that the trust was there immediately with Dalia because it already existed.
But even so, bringing.. in, in a sense, in that
situation, it's hardest for her
because she's got to bring a stranger into a
situation that is very painful for those,
for those, for those women, and if you read
the interviews that she conducted with them,
for this project, they talked about each time how the wound is opened up
and that is an extremely, extremely difficult thing for anybody to do repeatedly
in front of journalists or any one.
[Aida] I thought Dalia had someone who was kidnapped, because of the strong enthusiasm she had,
the way she captures a photograph, and how she was very sensitive with those who had missing loved ones.
[Dalia] Really? Actually my father was detained for 3 days during the war, I was very young. But then I learned
there is an estimated 17,000 missing.
[Aida] Where?
[Dalia] He was around Hamra, and then there was a swap of detainees… a very small militia.
Aida's husband Kamal was kidnapped in 1985 along with his nephew Sam Hahn, who was 22 back then,
as they were coming back from their work.
They never heard of them again.
They looked for them everywhere but in vain.
They were related to a friend of mine so along with Amal the mother and my friend I visited them at home.
Aida refused to be photographed at first,
even after Amal insisted.
I looked for the best place to take the photograph of Lena  and then I found out that
the living room was the closest to a window.
There were two chairs that were placed on each side of a small table and
on the wall behind them a painting was hanging.
Aida brought a framed portrait of her husband from the 80s and placed it on the table along with his pipe.
[Aida] I did not want to be photographed at the beginning.
And then I brought the photo of Kamal and put it, it was not there then [on the table]
and then I put the pipe that Kamal smoked. He loved smoking and I loved the smell of the pipe’s tobacco.
We remembered him at that moment, during the photograph.
[Dalia] As I moved the sofa facing the two seats and stood behind it to have more space and distance,
Aida suddenly sat on the seat and told me to take the photograph.
We were all shocked, Amal, Lina and myself.
she had resisted being photographed for over an hour while we were having tea earlier
so I just clicked three frames and then her
daughter sat for the portrait after her.
[Lina] For us she was a journalist, we know that a lot of journalists hold cameras, so not a lot changed for us.
We trusted her because we knew her, we saw her, we saw her behaviour, she was not like people who…
I mean when someone did not want to be photographed she did not insist.
There are many people who do not like to be photographed,
so she took into consideration that there are people who do not like to be photographed.
[Dalia] When I'd developed the films and scanned them I sent Aida's photograph to the Gedea's by email.
Both of them thought that the photograph looked very
empty
Amal and her daughter on the other side, thought it was beautiful and represented her situation
and the emptiness in her life.
I explained by email also that this was exactly what I was aiming at,
the empty chair that was supposed to be occupied by the husband
had she not been kidnapped.
Instead a photograph of him from the 80s
sitting on the table, as is time froze for him
after he was kidnapped.
In the photograph he's smiling when life was
obviously better for the family and
by coincidence he was looking at his wife Aida,
who has aged and who is looking at me
with sad eyes thirty years after his kidnapping.
[Aida] I felt that the house lacks life… the photograph...
Kamal is sitting next to me and I am looking at the camera. I did not see that it [the photograph] had…
[Lina] life in it.
[Aida] Yes.
[Lina] The empty chair. For example we did not take into consideration
that this photo is supposed to be for the missing person…
[Aida] For Kamal.
[Lina] It is part of the decoration [of our house]. But this caught their eyes [the people who saw the image].
The wall was also empty… They looked at the photograph in a different way that we did.
They looked at the eyes, the portraits at the table. The eyes… we did not look at it this way,
maybe because we are living the situation…
[Jeanette] Dalia has taken a very beautiful photograph of your mother. As if the photograph is reflecting
all her feelings. Her feelings along with the house and the empty chair…
… as if her life partner is missing in the house
[Aida] Dalia photographed well; she captured the idea.
[Benjamin] So there's nothing to be pitied
there that is a strength and a defiance
and an anger, mixed with a little bit of
hope that each day is getting spuffed-out.
So it's always a privilege and a pleasure to be in such a place as a welcome guest,
very much as a welcome guest.
But professionally...  professionally you're thinking .. "What do I need?"
.. and really that welcome and that trust,
it's ..it's only worth it for them, if you do a good job..
if you tell their story properly.
It's only worth the pain, that they have to go through when they open themselves up
if you meet that with a professionalism and a determination to get it right.
So that's, that's my role as a storyteller.
[Dalia] I have never put pressure on the families to be photographed
I totally understand their sufferings
and how they still decide to hold on to some of the remaining privacy in their lives.
Some people tell me their stories and years later they accept I visit them for the photographs,
while others still did not decide and are still considering.
[Benjamin] I always like to think that when we sit with someone and we ask
them to tell something of themselves.
Most of the time I'm very clear I'll be using this material
and I think that's quite important as well and..
and part of just being a professional.
[Lina] Of course there is no regret that we were photographed. Would we do it again?
I am not sure.
There is no negative feeling but it is enough, we are tired.
You keep repeating the same story, every time to someone new.
Every time a university student wants to work on the subject, you have to tell the story again.
Of course he wants to do a project.
But for us, it is enough.
[Benjamin] Obviously I'm very close to Dalia's project,
because I've sat with the women and I made a radio documentary and a film.
And, this morning I was thinking about what I wanted to say, particularly in relation to *you*
as the audience, looking at a photo
and how you might respond to that photo.
And the thing that I wanted to tell you was that,
the danger of a photo which I sort of, talked about earlier,
is that it holds someone in time, in moment.
it kind of says: "This is this is it",  right?
and life is not like that because it's much more complex
and people's feelings come and go and we have,
you know, waves, and up times and down times,
even anyone who's undergone trauma,
and distress, and loss.
[Jeanette] Correct, this is what my mother used to say -
Every once in a while, someone comes and opens the wound that was healing.
It really bleeds, especially with the father and mother.
We are tired, but we will not lose hope, until we know the truth, we will keep on fighting.
[Lina] We do not think the photos are not leading to anything.
[Jeanette] I would keep repeating it, because it is a wall I want to keep knocking on.
Every time a journalist or a photographer approaches us,
especially Dalia who had promised she wants to photograph [the grave] in the mountains,
I will always accept, because the politicians do not hear our voices.
Hopefully the media manages to achieve something, we will always keep demanding,
because there is no right that gets lost, when there is behind it people who keep insisting.
[Dalia] This project has taken me a long time to finish
and its a very mentally exhausting one.
Each story leaves me emotionally tired for days
and the fact that I would not settle on telling one side of the story
takes longer than it's been expected.
It is also a self-funded project so sometimes I need
to stop and work on my assignments
in order to survive and to save money to continue it.
But taking a long time to finish it gives me more time to think about it
and to brainstorm on how to make it, or take it,
to a deeper level.
I do not have a deadline so I decided to allow myself to do this
until I have a project that I'm, very proud of.
[Benjamin]  We just have to keep asking questions.
We have to do that all the time, and challenge our own assumptions,
and sometimes we need Dalia to have sat down with the women and just hear what they think
and it kind of takes away a lot of the formality of what you're seeing
and your feelings about what you're seeing.
In fact, what I would say is her interview with the women, in many ways,
is actually more humanizing than the photograph itself
and that's something really interesting to.. to reflect on.
[Jonathan] Thank You Benjamin.
There are lessons here not only within
the stories contained of the missing,
but there are lessons here for us on how
visual storytelling is done,
what the dynamics are in that process and there
are pointers as to how we can become
more sophisticated, as both media-producers and media-consumers.
There is a tension in photography and
there always has been.
An uneven distribution of power.
A necessary vulnerability.
The basic premise is the same,
photography enables us to see the world through the eyes and lens of someone else
And there's an intimacy in that. When a person brings a camera or a smartphone up to their eye,
there is immediately the photographer and the photographed.
And there will be the audience or the viewer as well at some point,
and the most powerful stakeholder
in those three-way relationships
is almost never the subject.
The subject must agree to be vulnerable not just once,
not just at the point of the
shutter release
that photograph may never be seen within the context that it was actually taken.
The chances are it will live on in many different contexts
even simultaneously
and its meaning might well shift with each audience
and each time the subject will be vulnerable again.
It's why these class interviews
are set up the way they are
between a photographer, a subject and an audience.
It's to explore that tension, and then for us to reflect on our relationships with the world
when we bring the camera to our eye and make the world our subject.
And listening to Dalia's conversation,
one of the things that's apparent is that telling someone's story is a speculative endeavor.
Dalia and Benjamin asked permissions of their subjects
in the full knowledge that they
they might well and often do say "no".
Dahlia talks of people agreeing to have
their photographs made years after she's asked,
and we begin to get a sense of the negotiation that takes place between the subject and the photographer,
and the importance of trust in that relationship.
It's also interesting to consider what
Dalia's work will come to mean in the future,
and that's something that applies
to all our work - it's difficult if not
impossible for us to know what our
images will come to mean in future contexts
and what their values might be
and to whom.
Which might then be problematic when we've negotiated or built a trust relationship with our subjects.
I mean.. what what did we promise?
What is their understanding?
What exactly did they give their consent for?
Have we been transparent and honest about what we can and can't promise?
Because when the subject appears as an image,
they're going to stand alone.
and we can't predict what the many possible feedback-loops (the consequences)
for that subject might be.
We all have a right carry a camera.
but does that automatically confer the right for us to photograph other people?
And if so then it's interesting to consider what the circumstances might be
where we would feel justified in doing so if say..
it made the subject feel uncomfortable,
distressed or scared.
This is one of the things that's so exciting about Dalia's work.
We don't know where it will lead,
but we know it's built on a foundation
of her asking those tough questions of herself
on a subject by subject basis,
exposing her own limitations and vulnerabilities
and we know that each image is a testament to that rigour and integrity.
It means that with each new layer of the evolving project, from
places, to artifacts, to portraits and
oral testimonies,
to a Facebook page and an Instagram feed, the project grows
as more and more people buy into that process that Dalia has set out.
So now is the time here in this session for you to put down your own moral markers.
To take a metacognitive view..  to step back and look at your own practice from a distance
and to spell out your best practice, your code of ethics.
You can also now access the deep dive materials
including the extended interviews and our interview with
World Press Photo winner Rena Effendi. In that
she reflects on all of the five course's
key questions, with reference to her work
and in particular, examples where
she's telling the stories of things that are
no longer there.
Don't forget to dig around in the class notes, investigate those hotspots and
see why particular parts of the conversations are being responded to and by whom.
Reach out, connect with people and
support those who can't get into a room of fellow students.
I'm Jonathan Worth and you can connect with me via Twitter:    @jonathan_worth